world leaders aren't the only ones
converging on New York for the United
Nations General Assembly climate
activists came by the thousands from
around the world too shouting their
message
right now the impacts of climate change
on the Caribbean and other parts of the
global South are absolutely devastating
and I'm here to bring attention to the
impact that our fossil fuel addiction
here in the global North is having on
communities like the one I come from
there isn't going drought in the Horn of
Africa including Kenya and Somalia that
is putting Millions at risk of the Via
hunger denying children the rights to
food education and water
the demonstration tees up the climate
ambition Summit on Wednesday called by
the U.N Secretary General to pressure
Nations to fulfill their commitments
made in the 2015 Paris agreement aimed
at keeping Global temperature rise below
one and a half degrees Celsius activists
are amplifying the call of you when
Secretary General Antonio Gutierrez
calling on world leaders to take
concrete actions to end fossil fuel
usage that message is directed
particularly at U.S President Joe Biden
they're demanding President Biden
declare a climate emergency Joe Biden is
the number one oil and gas producer in
the world right now
feeling gas expansion in the world so
we're asking President Biden to turn the
tide against fossil fuels and phase out
the fossil fuel era some activists have
gone beyond demonstrating in the run-up
today Summit 25 were arrested on
Thursday for blocking entrances to the
headquarters of Citibank one of the
largest financiers of fossil fuel
extraction around the globe after a
summer of record-setting heat as well as
floods and wildfires made more extreme
by Rising temperatures they say
governments can't wait any longer to act
Kristen salumi Al Jazeera New York
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera